8 months you grow 500,000 subscribers
what happened so Tik Tok had Banned Me
from their platform I was a little mad
at Tik Tok at the time said you don't
want my content okay I'm going to take
it somewhere else and I went all in on
YouTube so I had uploaded 600 shorts
before it clicked for me wow and those
were the top five useful websites videos
and in 3 days it exploded one of the
videos did uh 11 million views in a
couple days the one that went viral uh
which is a 50-second video drove about
270,000 subscribers wow which is crazy
that's funny too cuz we always say you
you are one video away from changing
your life YouTube and it might be video
number
653 but things can really change when
you crack that code so that's PR
inspiring